attitude contraste et au procès vilma
l'avocat général avait réclamé une peine
de 10 ans minimum contre jean-marie
villemin jugé pour le meurtre de bernard
laroche
la défense souhaite l'acquittement
dominique verdeilhan hervé poggio la
dernière touche avant la plaidoirie d'un
dossier que m chastan suit depuis plus
de huit ans jean marie villemin a fait
ce matin une confidence à son conseil
l'avocat général a fait mal à jean marie
villemin quand il a envisagé sa
dangerosité
le réquisitoire a scandalisé la défense
comme la scandalisé en 85 la rumeur qui
a transformé christine villemin en
criminel l'honneur d'une mère qu'on
jette aux chiens dénonce l'avocate
pensez vous que la justice puisse se
tromper deux fois interroge m chastan
autrement dit la première piste celle de
bernard laroche était la bonne pour
mettre robinet le corbeau est sûrement
venu à la barre et il cite nommément
frères et belles soeurs de l'accusé en
bloc la défense interroge la cour
d'assises comment devant ce
dysfonctionnement médiatico-judiciaire
jean marie villemin pouvait-il résister
m robinet invite les douze jurés à se
poser demain durant leur délibéré une
autre question
qu'auriez vous fait à sa place